[music]
Hello everyone. Um, today we'll be
talking about how to build coding
agents.
And uh, I'm Bill. I work on the applied
AI startups team at OpenAI.
>> And I'm Brian. I work with Bill on the
OpenAI startups team.
>> And we specifically uh focus on uh
building coding agents here at OpenAI.
Um yeah. So why are we talk giving this
talk? Why why are we you know u talking
about coding agents? Well, it's really
quite interesting because it's been
booming for the the the past year.
Actually, it's just if you think about
it, it's not that much time ago. like
only have been a year or so. The ground
keeps shifting really under the uh
harness on on the coding agents. But if
you think about it, it's really like why
it's interesting is because it's really
a signal on how close we are to AGI.
Software engineering can be set as a
universal medium for problem solving.
But because the ground is shifting so
fast, uh we h kept having to rebuild the
agent on top of the model whenever a
model is released. And today we're going
to talk a little bit about how we might
be able to get around that.
So here's what we're going to go over
today. We'll start with the anatomy of a
coding agent, especially going into the
details of models and harnesses and how
they work together. We'll share some
lessons that we learned from putting
them together ourselves. And we're
specifically going to talk about codeex
here, which is our own coding agent.
We'll talk a little bit about emerging
patterns that we're seeing from all of
you for using agents like Codeex in your
own products. And lastly, we'll talk a
little bit about what to expect from
Codeex in the future so that you can
build along with us if you want to.
To start, let's talk a little bit about
what makes a coding agent an agent as a
whole. Um, it really is quite simple. I
think you know people kind of over
complicate things a little bit these
days. It's made out of three parts. It's
a user interface. It has a model. It's a
harness, right? Uh the interface quite
self-explanatory. Could be a computer uh
like a CLI tool or it could be a uh
integrated developer environment, could
be also cloud or background agent. Um
models also very quite self-explanatory
are you know the things like the latest
and greatest the GPD 5.1 codeex uh max
that we just released yesterday uh or
the GPD 5.1 series of models or other uh
models from other providers as well. And
the harness uh is a little bit more of
an interesting part. This is the part
that directly interacts with the model
uh in the most reductive way. You can
sort of think of it as a collection of
prompts and tools combined in a core
agent loop which provides input and
outputs uh from a model. Uh the last
part will be our focus for today.
As touched on a bit earlier, coding is
one of the most active frontiers in
applied AI and uh how models are
constantly getting released and we're
not making the problem uh easier for
everybody
is that people have to constantly adapt
uh the agents to the new models.
So, um, Bill's done a great job of
giving us an overview of coding agents,
what they're made up of. So, let's zoom
in a little bit on the harness. Um, it
turns out that's a little bit tricky.
So, what is a harness? A harness is
really the interface layer to the model.
It's the surface area the model uses to
talk to users and the code and perform
actions with tools. It's made up of all
of the pieces that the model needs to
work over many turns, call tools, and
and really write code for you and
interpret what the user is actually
asking. [snorts] Um, for some, the
harness might actually be the special
sauce of the product. But as we're going
to go into a little bit more, it's
really challenging work to build a good
harness. And we'll talk about how we did
that.
So let's see what are some of these
challenges. Um just to name a few, AV is
one. Um your [laughter]
um your brand new innovative custom tool
that you're giving to your agent might
not actually be something the model is
using is used to using. It may not have
ever seen that tool before in trading.
And even if it is, you need to spend
time tuning your prompt to that
particular model and the habits that it
comes with.
And new models are coming out all the
time. What about latency? Like does the
model take a while to think about
certain things? Which things do you
prompt it not to? How do you expose the
UX of what a thinking model is doing
while it's thinking? Is it communicating
with you while it's thinking or do you
have to summarize it? Managing the
context window and compaction can be
really challenging. We just launched
Codeex Max that does that out of the box
for you. you don't have to worry about
compaction and context window
management. It's really hard to do. Um,
and so if you were to do it yourself,
have fun. Um, and then also like the
APIs keep changing, right? So we have
completions, we have responses, we have
whatever else is coming in the future.
What does the model know how to use and
get to get the most intelligence out of
the box?
And so
this is the interesting part. Fitting a
model into a harness takes a lot of
prompting.
It turns out that how the model is
trained has side effects.
I like to think about it this way.
Intelligence plus habit. Intelligence.
What is the model good at? What
languages does it know really well? What
is what is its capabilities in terms of
like how well it can write code in
certain frameworks? And then what habits
did it learn to to use to solve those
problems? We've trained our models to
have habits of like planning a solution,
looking around, gathering context, and
and thinking about a problem before
diving in and writing code, and then
testing its work at the end.
Developing a feel for these habits is
how you become a good prompt engineer.
If you don't instruct the model in ways
that it's familiar with, you can have
problems. We saw this when we launched
GPD5. A lot of people who weren't used
to using our models encoding tried to
take prompts that existed for other
models and put them into their harness
and have GPD5 follow those instructions.
And it turned out that we taught our
model to do some of the things that the
other models didn't really do out of the
box. And so when they were prompting
them to look really hard at the context
and like examine every single file
before making a a code edit, our model
was being very kind of thorough about
that and it was taking a really long
time and they weren't seeing the best
performance. And so we figured out that
if you let the model just do the
behaviors that it's used to and don't
overprompt it, it'll actually perform
really better. We found out by asking. I
was literally like, "Hey, like I like
the solution, but it took you a long
time to get there. What can I do
differently in your instructions to help
you get there faster next time?" And
literally it said, "Uh, you're telling
me to go look at everything and I don't
really need to. So that's what's taking
forever."
And so you can actually see the
advantages of building both the model
and the harness together because you
just like know all of that while you're
building it. And that's why Codex is
both a model and a harness combined.
So let's dig deeper into Codeex and what
it can actually do.
So we built Codex to be an agent for
everywhere that you code. It's a VS Code
plugin. It's a CLI. You can call it in
the cloud from the VS Code plugin or
from chatgbt from your phone. Um, and
it's very basic. You can use it to turn
your specs into runnable code starting
from a prompt. Um, having a plan. It
navigates your repo to edit files. It
runs commands, executes tasks, and you
can call it from Slack or you can have
it review PRs and GitHub. So, all of the
things that you would expect.
And that means that the that codec um
the harness of codec needs to be able to
do a lot of really complex things. Uh
when I talked to a member of the codeex
team about this slide and what should be
on it, he was like it's way harder than
you think. You have to manage parallel
tool calls like thread merging and all
of the things involved in that. Think
about all the security considerations
you have with sandboxing, prompt
forwarding, permissions, uh, port
management. Um, compaction is a whole
thing. Um, and doing that well is really
complex. When do you trigger compaction?
When do you reinject? How do you worry
about uh cache optimization during that
MCP, right? Like all of the uh plumbing
you have to build for MCP support into
the harness. Uh, and then not even
mentioning images and what's the
resolution that you need to compress
them to to send them to the model. All
this all of this is like work that you
have to do if you're going to build this
from scratch and keep it updated as new
features come online.
So since we've bundled all of these
features together for you in an agent
that can safely write its own tools to
solve new problems that it encounters.
Oops.
Uh we actually have here uh a computer
use agent for the terminal.
Wow, that sounds quite a bit powerful
than just plain old coding agent,
doesn't it? Um but just think about it
again. Well, before browser and graphic
user interface was a thing, wasn't that
how we always operate a computer?
they're writing code and chain them
together in a command line interface. So
that means if you can express your tasks
in command line as well as files tasks
codeex will be able to know what to do.
Um the example is I like to use codeex
to organize a lot of the photos from my
desktop into a folder and that's a very
simple use case but what it can also do
is it can analyze huge amounts of CSV
files inside of a folder uh doing data
analysis it does not have to be a coding
task and if it can be accomplished by
running tools from command line you can
use codeex
so now that we see codeex is such a cool
harness um I want to also share a little
a bit about how you can use it to build
your own agents. And what you can do is
you can use codeex [clears throat]
the agent inside of your own agent.
Um, how does that work? Well, if you
want to build uh a coding uh the next
coding startup, we don't really have all
the answers, but we do have a few
patterns uh that we thought uh might
help you having worked with some of the
top coding customers uh like cursor and
VS code. Uh one of those patterns is uh
harness becoming the new abstraction
layer. The benefits of this is quite
obvious. Um, you no longer have to care
about prioritize optimizing the prompt
and tools with every model upgrade.
[snorts]
>> But, um, does that mean you're just
building a wrapper?
>> Well, I disagree with that take.
I disagree. I was disagreeing with my
colleague here. Um, just like how
building rappers on top of models I
think is really reductive on uh on the
whole value prop of the infrastructure
layer. Sorry, I used to be a VC.
[laughter]
>> Focusing most of your efforts on
differentiating your product is what
this pattern allows you to do. And
that's where most of the value lies.
Exactly. Okay. So, let's look at some of
these patterns that we've seen and
actually have helped our customers build
um along with them. Codeex is an SDK. It
can be called through a TypeScript
library. You can call it
programmatically and a Python exec.
There's a GitHub action that you can
plug into to have it merge merge
conflicts on PRs that everybody hates
doing. Then uh you can also add it to
the agents SDK and give it MCP
connectors back to your product. So now
you have an agent. I like to say we
started with chat bots that you can talk
to. Then we gave the chatbots tools to
use. And then now you can give uh a tool
to your chatbot that can make other
tools that it doesn't have. And so now
you can actually build out enterprise
software that does it that writes its
own plug-in connectors to the API level
for each customer on the spot. That's
something that a professional services
team used to have to do. Um, so you have
fully customizable software that can now
talk back to itself. Um, I made a conbon
board for dev day that can actually fix
its own bugs. Um, it's pretty fun. And
then lastly, um, you can actually do
something like what Zed has done. They
have just decided to wrap codeex inside
of a layer and give it an interface to
the IDE for talking back and forth for
the user and making code edits. And now
they don't actually have to do all the
work of staying on top of all of the
things that we're good at doing and they
can focus on building like the best code
editor.
Uh so our top coding partners like
GitHub has used this uh to great effect
and well uh we've created an SDK uh for
it that they used to directly integrate
uh with codeex. You can also use the SDK
to uh control codecs as part of your
CI/CD pipeline as well as use it as an
agent that directly interacts with your
own agent as well. Uh [clears throat] if
you really want to customize the agent
layer, you can do it too. As an example
of this, we worked with closely with the
cursor team to get the best performance
out of the codecs. The model, not the
agent, we're bad at naming things. The
model is different from the agent. They
did so by aligning their tools to be in
distribution with how the model is
trained and they did so by aligning uh
their harness with our open- source uh
implementation of codeex CLI. All of
this is publicly available. Uh you can
fork the repo, you can use our source
code, you can use it. Uh go nuts.
So what does the future hold for Codeex?
It hasn't even been out for a year. Um
and especially with the lo la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la launch of CEX
match yesterday like things are really
changing fast. Uh it's the fastest
growing model in usage now serving
dozens of trillions of tokens per week
which has actually doubled since dev
day.
It's always good to build where the
models are going. It's safe to assume
that the models will get better. They'll
be able to get to work on much longer
horizon tasks unsupervised.
New models will raise the trust ceiling.
I trust these models now to do some way
harder work than I would have 6 months
ago. And that's going to keep
increasing. The future is about
sprawling code bases and non-standard
libraries and knowing how to work in
closed source environments, matching
existing templates and practices
and the models uh and and and so you can
imagine that the SDK will evolve to
better support these model capabilities,
letting the model learn as it goes and
not repeat mistakes and generally
provide more surface area for an agent
that writes code and uses a terminal to
solve whatever problems it encounters.
counters and you can use that in your
products via the SDK.
So, what have we learned? Harnesses are
really complicated and take a lot of
work to maintain, especially with all
the new models coming out. So, we've
built one for you inside of Codeex that
you can use off the shelf or look at the
source if you want to and you can use it
to build new things outside of coding
and let us do all of the work making
sure that you have the most capable
computer agent.
And we're really excited to see what you
craft.
[applause] Heat. Heat.
[music]